Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to Prey
So I need supplies to be able to make medkits
and the only place that I can go is
in here because I need- I need a lot of uh-
I need a lot of... plantlife(?) instead uh- not synthetics
but I need natural stuffs which means.....
there's a lot of guys that can blow up in here
and I wanna save 'em so what I'm gonna do is
e- oh I though I unlocked it
Oh, Here we go! Activate sprinklers
YAAH
Well that did nothing
Alrighty then~ that's nice but that guy's still over there
Fuck, alright so I gotta get in here and I gottuh-
Not let anybody blow up
Where is everybody?
Oh-- There they are!
Okay... Hi. Hello! How you doing?
Just gonna zap you.. come at me bruh
HABOOSHKI(?)
Woaahh and it'll put those guys under
And then they won't blow up!
Easy as that- uh oh I've been spotted. Oh boi
Eeee, just gonna get this guy UHH
Eeeeeeeeeee
I wanna see ya! OW! WHAT?
Something killed me
Oh boy
Well let me try that again
Oooh you're stim-stomping(????)
Don't get caught in that
Ohh blub- got you
Okay, so they're all unconscious now
Cool cool
So that means that I should be able to take care of this guy
(What?)
UOOOAYEEEHHYEYEYE
I can't take one more hit- I can't take another hit
So I'm just gonna y'know- save
Oh boi
HAHAYEYEYEYEHEYYY
Yahey
Okay
Almost there
Ow! Ow! Ow! OHHHHHHHHHHHHH!*starts making it into a song*
Not dead yet
HAHA! Popped(?) ya!
OKAY
Uh-huh
Uh-huh.. I am correct, am I?
Oooh look at all these fruits
So with this fruit, I can salvage it
It's not just for food although it is good for food
but it can salvage it and turn it into medkits
because there are so much of it
So with all this stuff...
I get to make what I need to make. So I'll be right back
Once I have everything in order but now I should be able to make enough medkits
go outside do the coral(?) thing and not have to worry about dying a horrible death
because I'll actually have HEALTHH
So I'll be right back once I got all that in orderrrrr
Okay, also I have a lot of neuromods right now
So I shoulddddddd
I should... get some of these more basic things which increase you know
the psi hypo they just made items more useful
along with the physician one which makes it easier to do that
I can get more psychoscope things all that good stuff
and then yay woah I could get more of these things, I could
there's a lot of things here ohh there are a lot of things here that are
awfully cooool. I guess it doesn't really matter now that they already recognize me
but maybe- ooooh
That's handy! OH! That's nice! OOOHH
Ahh I need to get another nightmare skin but that's okay on that one okay
And also I'm gonna get this one and I can get a lot of health
and I can always make more neuromods now because I have the thing
Sooo I am going to now go where I needed to go so I'll be right back once more again
Okay so I got all I need so I should be able to go out there
and do what I need to do. I- I don't have a lot
I don't have a lot of medkits but I do have a lot of health now up to 200 now
and if I get more- uh... neuromods then I should be able to upgrade that even further
which is gonna get me real good and if I- get away with taken damage then I should be in good shape maybe?
So, either way I'm gonna try and get this coral skin maybe that sounds
like something that I would wanna do *breathes in*
This technology though, I don't know
I think the after word might be to say that it's cursed uh 'cause he's using alien
not technology he's not even using the alien technology he's using an alien biology
if you can even call it that because the typhon I don't even know if they're like of this universe
I don't even know what they really are I don't think any of us actually do for some reason they're able to remap my memory
and then maybe it's all to do with this coral stuff BUT I got what I needed. Can you open up for me now?
Oh there you go, okay I was late on then one. So now I just gotta go down there
and I just gotta get this shit
Small little (?) huh. Ooh hi! Oh- okay! You know what Imma scadadle
Ohhhhhhh nelly! Ohhh ow! Owie~ Oh ow! Oh ow! Ow! Okay
Oh! That's not good! (?) please can I just have this?
Please just give it to oh! OHMYGOD OHMYGOD OHMYGOD
Fucking hell.
Woahhhhhhhhokay I'm outta here! OKAY!
Yeah I know that don't ask me how I know!
Uh-huh
Huah that's weird
Just one more huh?
Oh shit it's right there
woah
What the fucking? Get me! Nononononono
You just stay over there
How do I cha- drift off into space forever?
That sound like something you wanna do. Okay you do that
So I just gotta get in here. Apparently the coral is right around the corner
So..
Seems like some kind of a secret entrance. There's a lot of lightning it's probably not good
Oh boi
Wait is it- Oh no! This isn't even the way in I remember this! This is where I got this Q-Beam! Ohh- hi
Maybe not. Hello?
Uh-oh
That's so weird
That's so weird because I've seen reployers everywhere in this game and uh
Why does no one seemed to- oooh thread in a needle woooh!
Okay we're gonna make a fast fly by here oh I'm gonna- hang on I'm gonna ooh
No that's not I'm gonna do, I'm gonna do this! And I'm gonna repair my suit up just a little bit.
Eh eh eh*weird sounds*
Just so I can have armor going into this son of a bitch. Oh boi
But I- oh I stopped. Ohhhhhhhhhh boi. Ohhhhhh boi. Ow! Ohhhhhhhhhh ow!
Heraboshki! OOOH!
Oooooh
Ahhhh
Ohhhh
Wait a minute I have a funny feeling
that I'm being lied to and there's a different reeeason why all this is here
There has to be a different reason, right?
I'm thinking what I'm thinking now is that there must be like... all this is fabricated
Not all of this like the the invasion or whatever eventhough I think maybe that was orchastrated
but Morgan is fabricated you know what I mean?
That whole concept like*shrugs*
It seems like Alex was there in that little figment(?) of memory with a bunch of medical robots all around me
saying you know there was some problems going on and I'm thinkin I'm thinkin maybe I'm not the real Morgan afterall
which is something that I thought early on in the game I thought maybe I (???) there was something going on about this
Uh-huh
Uhhhhh
Uh-huhhhhhh uhhhhh
Okay, alright, sure, okay, oh yeah, oh yeah I believe you. Now what I don't know....
Uhhh, so I gotta get Alex's arming key ooohh
So I gotta get that somehow, I don't think I have the fabrication plan to that yet unless I do I don't know how to check unless I go to a fabrication thing
I'm wondering it's gonna be very bad if I do upload this you know, like cataclysmicly bad is in I can't change anything
You know what I mean?
I'm just curious... Just curious
Oooh neuromods. Thank you
Anti-rad, oh that's- oh these are nice. So do you just fly by and uh drop stuff up for me?
'cause that's awfully nice I suppose but also why- okay whatever so...
Utilities uhh repair looking glass. OHHHH
Well that- oh! that's handy! I'm glad they put a button in for that. HAIYAAAAH. Okay
EP101
Upload coral scan *breathes in* ooohhh
I don't know if I wanna do this but I'm just gonna see 'cause I can't make any assumptions before I do this
UH-OH
Kaspar?
Oh
Woah
OHh
But why? I was about to blow everything up!
I don't like the sound of that
Oh
But that seems bad
Oh. Hi, are you friendly?
Whip my ass(?) okay
Oh boi, ow wha- okay there we go
Hold still hold still hold still right there
BOOOOOOOOOM
Oh
Huh what do you mean? I'm in a battle here! Oh, hey.
I'm in a freaking fight to the death.
We've got fucking military operators all over the place
Yahey it's not my fault. Oh
Ummm
Hmm
Huh
Okay, that doesn't seem very uh family-friendly I'm thinking that there's gotta be some regrets about that later on
Can I just get your arming key and blow this all up because I don't like being lied to
Alright where am I going?
Where is this command shuttle? Alex is hiding until Dahl and his tech officer are disable
Okay but where are they?
Oh, down there? Ohh I must need to get down to the Arborethum or um the main lobby
Oh hey nonononono. Ah WHY AM I STUCK? YAYAYAYA
Uh-huh
Ohh... OW WHAT THE FUCK? GOD WHY IS EVERYTHING LIGHTNING?
Why does everything have to be lightning? Fuck, man!
Here we go, here we go. Shortcut shortcut shortcut
Lalalalala okay you're good
Go go go gooooooo
Let's go. Okay either way we gotta get down to this command shuttle and we gotta take care of this bullshit
because there's something fishy going on here
and they took over and I don't wanna be dealing with all that right now
I wanna be dealing with what I got in front of ma face
If they can do that for me I would be very happy
Oh boi
I know Dahl will know I'm coming
Yeah
Oh
WHA-?
I- I WAS- OH COME ON! I was just- *Mark speechless*
By Deep Storage! Ah, fuck
Uh-oh, ow! WHA- WHAT?! OH YOU FUCKING ASSHOLES
Goddamit I didn't even get out of the goddamn door
You fucking assholes
Oh, fuck
Can I- go go MOVE FASTER NOW!
WHY DID YOU JUST FREEZE THERE!
oHHHHH
Alright, fine I'm coming up to you I'm coming up to you
I'm coming up to you. Fucking hell I just stand by the goddamn door
Hi, what is it?
Yeah
Uhhh
Uh-huh
Uh-hm
Ahh
Ah
Hm
Uh-huh
HUH
I can do it
I CAN DO IT
I'd rather not kill people
Die for I'm fine but
Huh..
You don't know that!
Well, that's rude
Well, okay
I feel like you're mocking me and I don't really know who you are so that's a little rude of you
So if you could just not do that would be absolutely greeeeeeat
Okay, so I need to get rid of this and this annnd that's all about I can do.
I'm keeping this, I don't care. Gotta get that, eventually.
One of the side missions that I wasn't able to do. What are you doing over there?
Are you cowering in the corner? You okay?
Uh-huh, yeah
He must! You don't know, you don't know that. He might not
Okay, so I'm gonna need more disruptor because I'm gonna stun 'em and I need the disruptor to be able to do that
So I'm gonna take that right there ah
Then I'm gonna head out yah
And I'm gonna disrupt them and then remove their neuromods
Now... how you rem-...
Well, that sounds weird
Okay, I don't like th-
I don't like this wooooah I'm gonna go. Weeeeeee
Wooh woah woah. Okay, I made it alright, apparently
Okay can I go through here? Unlock, okay! I'm gonna go to the shuttle bay because apparently that's easy to do. Ha. He's gonna know I'm coming though
Ugh
Also I don't know why it's so hard to remove a tracking bracelet. Why wouldn't you just be able to do it? Why don't you just take it off? Is it embedded to your skin or something?
Maybe for security reasons they wouldn't want people to take those off but oh well
I'm gonna scadadle on in here and I'm gonna find- ooh hi
Oh, oh okay there's a lot of things there. Time for me to go incignito
Alright
Hang on
I'm aaa box lalalalala lalalalala I'm very slow lalalala oh didi oh didi oh didi ladidi ladada. Okay
Fuck, leverage
Uh-hmm
Nah, can't help ya I don't know what you're talking about but I have no idea where you are or how to help ya
So I think that you are on your own. Dang, I would be able to go through that door but I can't lift that I don't have enough leverage and I don't-
Do I have the neuromods to be able to get leverage?  Oooh I might. I've got 5. Oh- AHH you need 6! Aww, naw. Aw, naw
Okay, you know what I'm just gonna go for it. Frick you
No key card for the.. employee entrance. How 'bout the bathroom? Huh... Is there anything here that I can use? At least some organic material would be nice
Maybe I can just salvage a bunch of shit and then I'll be able to make some medkits out of that but some weird logic that I'm not gonna dive too deep into
Ugh.. maybe that's a bad idea
Hello? At least I can get these flowers. Didn't need to shoot that I forgot that I don't have a melee
Haduski. Anybody got anything they want to donate to the salvage yard?
Nah, nah? Alright, fine, flying down the middle huh
I can do that I've got magical powers. OH, okay. Ow! Oh those turrets. Goddammit. Fucking things are everywhere. Okay
but I should be able to sneak by if I use my stuff, oooh okay nevermind I ran out of- *sighs*
WHY? WHAT? Oh boi oh boi oh boi. Uhh, oww goddamit
Well, that went about as fast as it could go. Wait this!
Okay, oh that's not good
SHUMP WHOMPY WHOMPIN WHOOPY BAM. Okay
Good God, what was the point of that? Okay.
Well, I run out of power. D- whoaaaaaa okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna go. Oh my God I should've ohhhhhhhhhhh
I didn't save before I went like an idiot and then I just ran out in the middle of a fight. DON'T ASK ME WHY I DID THAT or why I thought that was a good idea.
I just panicked 'cause that thing was about to pop out a new operator and then I don't know what happened but it was very dumb.
OHHHHH. WHAT? WHAT HAPPEN?
Why can't you just be dead you fucking asshole. Oh my God. Let me just morph into that
Can you guys tell? Can you guys tell? Can you tell? Okay
Okay. Ohh come on. Come on. We're fine, we're fine. Everything's fine everything's fine. Oh my God. Oh, where do I gotta go where do I gotta go.
I gotta go right down in the middle. Nope, yes. Whoop whoop whoop, okay going down here now. Ohhhhh okay.
We're down here. Hello, can I take your stuff? Got a wrench fabrication plan that's what I needed.
Well, that's depressing but I got the shuttle control room key card which is good I guess. It's gonna be useful I think.
Oh, man that was a blind panic from start to finish. Ugh, okay so let me save 'cause I'm in a relatively good place and if I could just use my goddamn armor kits which I got a bajillion of.
and we should be okay and I don't know where to go but I'm gonna go here or somewhere, hello
Yeesh. Unlock that which is good? Ooh fabricator no, salvager. Almost as good, not quite as good but you know kinda good.
Oh, I've also got more stuff to make pistol gun but then I have no organic material
Like, organic material's something that is actually very very sparce around here.
and I don't know why, not sure why it's so sparce.
It just seems like something would be a little less rare but oh well.
They can't just be choosen and I'm just gonna have to what I can with it. We're almost to were we need to go.
Mmm'kay here turn that off whoooo did that?
Who do you think you are? Whoa, hi okay alright then I don't know if I wanna unlock that.
You know just saying, I don't think I wanna unlock that that seems like a room of death.
Where does this go? You didn't tell me there was another entrance just right here? OH into the Guts. I didn't know that you can go into the Guts from here.
That would've been smart for me to actually do that but then again I like to charge blindly into the fray
Is there anything down there that I can get? Ooh radiation that's- WOAH who's- WHAT THE FUCK?
What didn't I get no alert that I was being lasered? It's just like oh casually lasering. Oh yeah, that's no problem.
Goddammit okay, I gotta get up there but this command shuttle is up high and I'm down low, okay
So how in the hell do I get from no- STOPPPP
FUCKING ASSHOLESSS! Come on come on, try. Woah how did you do that?
Okay, I'm just gonna go 'cause fighting him seems to be a (???) at this point.
and I'm gonna go in here this is the best I can do. Ohhh I don't wanna do this but I got nothing. I don't- I got a whole lot of nothing.
I'm gonna do recycler charge
OOPS That's not what I meant to do.
Oh boi
Did that work? WOAH it didn't work, well it almost worked. Woah, hey okay there we go. Okay, well alright then where is- the body go?
Woah, I don't know where are the corpses went but okay. Where did the corpse go?
There's a lot of stuffs in here anyways, that's good. Okay, that and what do we have here?
Utilities. Oh, Grav Shaft
HOOKay UGGGH
UGH
Okay,
Alright, there we go. Jeez. A fucking nightmare that was.
And I still don't where the voltaic ones corpse went because I- oh there it is. Got that.
Okay, so I turned on the Grav Shaft
What the fuck? Oh God.
Uh, that's so sad. Is that the same guy that was outside also what's with these drawings?
It's like a Typhon dragon
Ugh.
Fucking weird.
Okay, there's something in the locker room here? What's in here? Why was there an objective in here? What is this?
Oh, this is weird. Okay. Okay.
Okay, I don't know why I- why does it say multiple objectives right there?
It's so weird. I have no- oh here? No. Here? No? What the hell are you talking about then? God, I have no idea. Okay, either way I'm gonna keep going.
Just nice.
Nothing in there. A medkit which is awfully nice I don't seem to get anymore of those. I can get a leverage! Oh, NICE!
Oh a fabricator which could be very useful, what does it say?
Yeah, you're goddamn right I need more of 'em but okay. At least I can make some shotgun shells 'cause I'm running low on that.
My favourite shooty shooty is running low
Ughh that's all I can make. Ughhhhhhh it's not good enough. Recycler charge, maybe
Okay, that's it for me. I gotta get going that was all that was in here I guess it was just some bonus items and nothing really except this Grav Shaft
he was talking about 'cause I don't understand how to get up there more than I already have. I got- there's gotta be some way to lower that down.
Oh, is that like a control room up there? I did get a key card for that. Oh my God I'm walking in the middle of everything. I didn't even realize it. Oh my Godd
Ohhhhhhhh, hey hi everybody. Hello didn't mean for this to happen. Oh that was a mistake, hi. Okay. Grav Shaft!
Look! Ooh, ah dead body, great! Okay. So I have to somehow gone in here so I'm just gonna oh I'm gonna unlock this just in case I fall out.
Whoop, okay we did that now. I'm gonna go up the Grav Shaft weeeeeeeee I think it's what I need to do is somehow I did it before I needed to know I did- okay.
Just gonna, oh hi Typhon oh boi ohhhh let's get out of here. Uhhhhhhhhhhh. Okay. Made it. Fucking hell. Hi, okay how you doing?
I made it in here I don't know how I don't know why I need suit repair ohhh.
Blind panic all the way.
Uh-oh uh-oh, yes something was just right in front of you, yeah you didn't know
Umm, one more please. Whomp very slow whompage there. Alright. Okay. I know I lost one more.
A facility? Where? What?
What?
There was a facility out there, oh that's so weird.
Why was there a facility out there that was not Talos 1? That's super strange.I have no idea.
Oh, okay alright think I'm done there.
Okay, again with the rat thing. Okay, yeah yeah alright
Okay, thank you. Yeah, that makes me feel good.
When are rats needed in the first place? See your aligory there doesn't really make any sense I just feel like you're lost and I'm not certain about what you're talking about
So what is this? Extend jetway. Oohh ahhh but it's too high huh.. Flight system check.
Ohhhh that's how you do it. Okay all systems nominal so what I need to do is I need to get in there and I need to beat the shit out of him?
With a stun gun? 'Cause that's what I'm prepared to do I'll do that I'm gonna do it, I'm gonna do that, I'm gonna do that. Eh, eh hello open up ding dong wow wow hello?
Anybody wanna get zapped? Hello? Where you at buddy? Where you at buddy boo? Where are you buddy Where you at? What's going on here? Look at this food in here living in the luxury you are.
Well, thanks. Take those so why please wait? Are you in here?
Hmm
Well, I can't get in there Dahl's cargo hold. If he's in there where he is.
Weird.
Guess he wouldn't be in a shuttle guess it would make a lot of sense. Ooh. Oh, here we go. Files. Uhh...
Okay, okay.
Oh, he didn't oh okay. So there's a scaredy officer somewhere in the neuromod division uhh
So I need to go over there. This was a lot of fighting to get a little bit over there. Oh frickin God- oh hey okay then you know. Great
Great. Wonderful. Come on. Come at me. Where you at? I'm ready for ya. You know what I'm just gonna go for it the other way that I found
It's gonna be uh- laserrrr. Ohohohoho ow owww oww owie. Okay, either way we made it out of here and we can get out of here because we need to get to neuromod. HEUH
It's just a nightmare! Everywhere you go! Why would anybody be expecting to kill everything in here it's so horrible.
Either way I gotta get to neuromods that means I gotta go back to where I originally was.
Eugh, somewhere in the beginning of the game whatever they were doing to this tests, I don't know
I don't know nothing I just do what I'm told but probably gonna end up blowing up everything but why does he want to kill-
Why does the(???)
Uh
Uhhh
Huh, what? Wha?
Wha? Oh God oh God oh God. What- what do you mean cargo bay? Ohhh no
Uh-oh ah ahhh. Oh God
What? What?
Ha@!$!% Hang on. Oh, HI! OH BOI
What? OHhhhhhhhkay. Well, does that mean I need to go to life support or what? Ugh..
Okay, I need to uh pffh. I do need to go to life support. Okay I'll do that. I feel like saving people 'cause that seem to be the right thing to do!
Uhhhhhhh! UGHHH! Why everything gotta be horrible all the time? Ugh. Alright, what do we got?
Fucking duck(?) Oh my God that was so hard and why is it such a long delay just to get out of the goddamn gate?!
Oh boi. Okay, whatever. It's fine. I'm fine. Everything is fine.
So as long as we can get in here and get out in enough time we should be okay and then I'll save them and go up to neuromod kick the science officer's ass
'cause this just been one blinding like spurt through the beginning and up the ass.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, uh-oh
Uh-huh
Yeah, okay
Whatever you say, man whatever you say. Mkay. This guy- this guy's kind of an asshole. You know what I'm just gonna
I'm gonna go for it. Oh boi. OHH what is happening there?
I'm just skate on by- ohhhhhhhhhkay. I'm just gonna skate on by don't mind me.
Don't mind me(??) Woooooooooooh, woooooooh I'm going tooo get some suit repair in here
Okay, okay. OH GOD, MORE OF YOU ASSHOLES! Yeeeeeee, okay. Alright, just gonna slide into ohhh
That was a bad slide. Oh, frick. Okay. Okay.
Where am I going? Where am I going? Where am I going?
I need to go oxygen flow control, Dahl? Dahl is right there? Hey! What the fuck? This is my private space!
Ohhhh God oh God. Ow ow ow ow
There we go, one down. Ohhh no, okay there we go.
Fuck, okay so Dahl is somewhere up there. If I can just pull his frickin arming chip or his neuromods out then he should be
should be easy to get but I just need to go down. Oh my God! They're so fast. Ohhhhhhhhh bolski
Woah, got one of 'em. Wait, no that's not what I wanted. Oh, frick.
This, SHABOOM! Okay got 'em down, okay. Those are down. Oh nonono
Come here, come here you bitch! Blap! Okay. Oh boi.
I'm doing but pftt at what cost? Fuck, okay.
What's this? Okay. So I gotta go get down and I gotta zap 'em. It's just what I gotta do.
Where is he? He is slightly up above- ooh hey.
Okay, I gotta save enough zap to be able to get him. That's what I gotta do.
Okay, uh.. I can use another recycler charge...
Well, that made it easy.
Alright, thank you x8
Okay, okay so he is... where? In there, okay. Alright. Okay. Alright, I'm down. I'm down to clown(?)
Let me play. Is this hacking 4? I can get hacking 4 can't I? Do I have enough neuromods?
Ohhhh again why am I always 1 off? Oh, I'm always 1 off.
Goddamit, there's gotta be another way in there. There just has to be, right?
Plfff there has to be.
Okay, what is this? Console fan controls. Check fans.
Oh.
Alright, it looks pretty locked down. Fan 3 jam.
Fan interrupt. I don't know what's this gonna do. Ooh jam maybe I can get in that way. Oooh maybe maybe baby. Oh.
There's something, oh. Ah. Okay so what do- what does it do for me?
What good was that? But it was jammed but I interrupted it, so that's AHHH come on!
Ohh, your stupid lasers. You don't look cool you know. You just don't look cool.
Organize this thing, here.
Eat one of those. Jump here.
Okay, and then uh check fans
It must be doing good. Okay all fans okay!
Uhhhh
Weird. So what should I do about that?
Still can't get in there.
Goddamit, okay so there's gotta be a way uhh.
There's gotta be a way for me to get one more neuromod but also oh God.
I'm working on it. I'm working on it. Don't worry. I'm working on it. Oh, I gotta figure out how to get in here. Was this then
Scadooshki
Alright, anything in here? Nope. This is a way around. Scadooshki
Okay, what's in here? Nope, that's what I'm not looking for. There's gotta be something else in here. Utilities.
Initiate decontamination
Woah, fucking hi.
Whooo, okay so what did that do?
Okay, so what did that do? What do I do about that?
Oh, oh oh
Wait, what? Ooh, OH. Okay.
I didn't know I did that
Okay,
I didn't understand what was happening.
Well, that was weird. Okay, alright then. Well, hahahaha.
Okay, alright.
So how do I get over there now? I still have to get in there. Like, how do I get in?
I can't get in I still can't get in!
Oh, how do I do that? I don't know. Wait- th ooh it's that easy! OH there's- there was a freaking window and that- that's how easy it is.
OKAY, alrighty then. How about I just- can I- oh. I can fix this, okay. Boink and take that put it in there. Ohhkay.
Oh my God, okay we did it. There we go
Easy as simple.
Okay, whatever you say. Don't need to be so dramatic about it, so what do I gotta do? Do I gotta carry him here?
Naw, there's no way I gonna carry him all the way over there. They said they were gonna get a medical transport arrange and that means...
What the fuck is this? Oh, it's this again? Really?
Uh-oh. Oh this was a mistake.
Well, apparently Remmer didn't want to play nice. So, I don't know about that. Didn't think it was pretty cuttin dries(?) as it was.
Okay, so I gotta get back up to uh my office I think it's where I'm gonna go.
Cause that would be the logical place where I would meet them and then hopefully that means we're gonna have a person to take us out of here
which is what we need to be able to survive this mess. I don't even know if survival's on the menu but...
Uh, anything's better than being here.
And I know if I go up that elevator then I'm gonna be thwarmed with a bunch of bullshit.
as per usual but maybe I could just.. maybe I could just kind crouch down maybe they won't see me.
I can't even crouch in here. Okay, that's good.
Well, here we go blindly walk in to death again.
Once more.
Here we go. Oh boi oh boi oh boi. Ow ow ow oh I'm ready for the ow! OHH OOOII WOOOAH OWWW
There's the o-o-ow oh you sacks of shit. Why did they make it like that. Why? Oh my God. Okay. Hello. Hi.
Hello?
Where? Where did you get more supplies? I don't see anything.
Uh, well I seem to be full of bullshit here. Ughhh
Okay, this is fine. Everything's fine, everything's good.
Good, recycle that up. Was I not suppose to come here?
Where am I suppose to go? Where's the- where's the objective action take me to the trauma center or something?
Save Ronny, save the tech officer. Wait for further instructions? Oh, that's not gonna help me.
That's not gonna help me at all!
Alright, fine then. I guess that is what it is. I came up for no reason.
Goddamit,
Oh I needed to go to the neuromod division anyway, what did you say?
Okay.
Uh-huh
Okay, alright then. So I need to go to the neuromod room and meet them there.
Which is super cool and something I'm happy about.
Okay, woah
Okay, I can do this! Whoop! Nnnnnnn- ohhhhhhhhkay.
It's fine oh it's fine. Dididadlydididadlydididaly
(??) would be nice.
Oooh can't make that up. Okay, here we go.
It's the nightmare down here
Shibibidibibidibibidiboo
Okay, we're good.
Man, this is crazy run around that gotta be going around here.
Feels like a frantic sprint from start to finish. This whole episode just been nothing but chaos.
Ugh, frick. We're okay.
For now, anyway I'm shocked I haven't died that much. I mean in the beginning I died a bit too but uh my God.
Talk about the climax of this story here.
Okay, come on any minute now. I mean the neuromod is a very impresive place.
but- woaaaaaahhhhhhhkay okay ohh I'm just gonna you have fun there!
Fuck, it's exactly what I mean.
This is a frickin sprint OH COME ON OWIEEE
HAH I got something from the simulation lab some key code I don't know what but I got it.
Okay, just gonna sneak by...real stealthily... oooh I made a mistake.
Oh I made a- @#%!@
Oh boi, I think I made goofs(?) oh I made so many goofs(?) Ugh
Oh oh there's so many! WOOO
WHAMP OH COME ON!
Eh, YAY, Ohkay
Okay, I did it.
Okay.
Yay
Uh-huh yeah sure.
Okay, yeah sure. Okay.
Why did you do that?
Yeea
Oh shit not that way woooahh. How do I get out of here again? I totally forgot it's been so long weeuh I think through here. Okay.
Good God. Oh my God. Oh my GOD.
EH. Ohh. Let me bash you again. I just want your shit.
I'll pull your guts out. Also it's giving me a lot of Q-Beam ammo. So I might as well just use the Q-Beam because I've got lots of it.
Ugh
Look, I knew there was a good reason for me holding this thing around. Ship.
Okay, come on hurry up! I ain't got all day.
Okay there we go. Ohh ohhhhhh oh my God. Well that's shockingly effective.
Okay. Alright then. What is that for? Control panel for what?
Grav shaft? What is it- guessing this is the second floor.
Alright. Hope for the best here. Well they're all dead.  That's a good sign. Oooh that's not a good sign.
Ohh that's not a good sign.
Ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow ow owwwwwwww
Nailed it. Okay so, anyways that is all the time I got for this episode. We are rapidly approaching the end of this game but we're not quite there yet.
We still have the ultimate decision to make. So, thank you everybody so much for watching. Hope you enjoyed this wild ride of an episode and uh
as always I will see you in the next video. BYE-BYE!